انتخابات بلديه تتويج واحتفالات تركت
المملكه المتحده في غرفه انتظار فما وراء
الاستمراريه المطليه بالذهب لاحتفالات
التتويج ادله عده تؤشر الاستعداد كلا من
بريطانيا وعائلتها المالكه لعصر جديد رغم
ان التغيير غير مضمون او حتى واضح الا ان
بريطانيا تقف على اعتاب التغيير في كل من
السياسه والنظام الملكي وفقا لصحيفه
نيويورك تايمز تتويتش تشارلز ادى الى قلب
الصفحه بشكل نهائي على حكم والدته الذي
دام سبعين عاما ووضع النظام الملكي في
خانه المستقبل غير مؤكد مع تراجع نسبه
المؤيدين الاستمراريات النظام الملكي كما
ان الهزيمه المؤلمه للمحافظين في انتخابات
رؤساء البلديات تشير الىنا الحزب الحاكم
في بريطانيا يمكن ان يخرج من السلطه في
الانتخابات العامه وبعد ثلاث سنوات من
خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الاوروبي وتسعه
اشهر من وفاه ملكتهم لا تزال البلاد تتلم
س طريقها للحصول على هويه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات